the ending sucks that ending there you
can see how it falls off a cliff yes
ending needs to be changed for future
videos yeah yeah yeah and this one
actually there was like an easter egg
which kind of proves that easter eggs
don't really work the ending should
never be in my view a like subscribe
comment down below i i've never asked
people to subscribe to my channel i
never asked people to like the video and
yet we have three whatever million
subscribers the ending you see how that
falls off at least on that video that
sean cho that's what most people do
thank you guys so much for watching i
hope to see you soon don't forget to
like subscribe as soon as you use
language that makes it feel like the
video is over people will leave
and where are they leaving maybe there's
somebody else's video or they close
youtube your goal if you want youtube to
recommend you a lot more your goal is to
continue the session so even though it's
the end of the video recording for you
it's just the end of the first quarter
for the person watching the video and we
want them to go binge on more of your
content if you can teach youtube that
when people watch one of your videos
they end up watching five seven eight
they will recommend you a heck of a lot
more so the call to action at the end
needs to be if you like this video go
watch this one here if you like this
interview with evan i've talked to him
before as well the link is right there
next to me go go watch it right there
i'll see you there now i'll see you soon
not thank you for watching i'll see you
right there you look to it you point to
it and you guide people that go click on
that end card right there